Coca-Cola
so uh welcome to to my talk which is
titled fuzzy matching at scale
uh we're going to be we're going to be
fuzzy matching on on a scale that we've
never seen
that is the introduction um
so so my name is tessal I'm a data
scientist and uh I have an experience
um in consultancy and and after
consultancy I I engaged in a few
interesting projects so I thought I'd
begin uh talking about them as an
introduction before we motivate the the
reason for this talk
so
I worked for the government during covid
developing spatial epidemiological
simulations to model the spread of covid
given seating events
and after that I moved into real estate
and
and what we're seeing here is
the international migration uh the the I
was managed to pull out using NLP from
an Airbnb data set so the Airbnb data
set has hosts and listings and you can
use the host description to pull out
where they're originally from so we
actually created an interesting map of
International foreign property interests
using NLP and the the talk that we're
doing today is also uh along those along
those lines uh it's a talk about NLP and
it's talked about fuzzy matching at
scale uh so this graph kind of motivates
the talk uh so the incumbent methods for
fuzzy matching are very slow so we're
going to understand why they're like
this we're going to introduce newer
methods which which scale uh and and
hopefully uh provide you all with some
information and a package that you can
use
so before we start uh what is fuzzy
matching so fuzzy matching is the
matching of two strings which are very
similar but have certain errors uh and
what's kind of what what do these arrows
entail so they could be insertions of a
character into a string there could be a
deletion a substitution or transposition
so if we have something like a UV so an
insertion would mean an introduction of
a character of Y into the middle of that
and and so on uh and and these four kind
of operations uh Define the majority of
the errors that are found uh in in this
kind of strings that we see uh uh kind
of kind of in industry
so the added distances are ways that we
characterize uh differences between two
strings there's a few of them and you
might have heard
um uh you might have heard of a few of
them so for example there's there's
levinstein longest common subsequence
Hamming distance uh jar Winkler
um and Dameron levenshein I was
wondering if you've if you've heard of
any of these it's kind of kind of hands
up or yeah you probably yeah that's
great
um and that there really isn't kind of
much of a difference that they're really
used for kind of kind of various various
purposes but the majority of the fuzzy
matching that's kind of done in Industry
probably uses Levenstein through a
package like fuzzy wuzzy on
so what does that algorithm look like so
the goal is we seek to compute an added
distance between two strings of
characters just using 11 shine
operations for now the non-symmetric
attic distance between two strings so we
can call the string kind of A and B is
given by some Matrix as defined in in
this kind of recursive relationship but
if if we try to try to compute this this
algorithm recursively uh we find that
it's it's very bad at scaling and it
scales exponentially
and so what we can try to do is we can
use dynamic programming to do to kind of
increase the runtime of that this
algorithm a notable example of a
Levenstein algorithm implementation is
the Wagner Fischer and that actually has
a very long history and it's got uh and
it's it's probably co-invented many
times uh over the kind of the last half
of this century
um needleman and bunch some of you might
recognize that because uh that's
actually a kind of a a fundamental
algorithm in in bioinformatics uh but
but but still we see that the time
complexity and the space complexity is
still uh not where we want it to be
um so the this is some pseudo code that
that the shows kind of uh why the space
complexity is so bad so
so this function we're declaring a kind
of a uh an integer array and and and
essentially that that Matrix needs to be
stored in memory during the computation
and and you can see the the earlier
recursive relationship that's kind of
kind of mirrored in the in the
subroutine there
so
um let's try to understand what this
algorithm does by using a case study and
I tried to Google the the most uh
awkward misspellings uh that there were
and
uh this is one of the safer ones that I
found
um yeah I'll give you a minute to see if
you find it so I'm not sure if you found
it but maybe maybe that would help
um so there we go it's not it's not a
huge mistake but it is but it's a very
small mistake so it's a Martin and
Martian are very similar strings and and
they they just differ on that there is
one insertion just at the second last
last point
and and we can use this as an uh to
understand how the the algorithm works
so the the the kind of the inner loop
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to uh fill up this Matrix and we're
using uh the the values of kind of
what's to the to the left above and to
the kind of the top left uh kind of uh
uh indices to fill it
um
but actually this is this is quite
interesting because I told you that the
wagon official algorithm for love and
shine has uh a space complexity of o m m
n multiplied by n but actually we can
see kind of from from that graph that we
only really need are two rows of that
Matrix to compute a cell so so we can
actually improve the space complexity to
either Owen or or om whichever one is
the smallest if we only store two rows
this means of course that we can't
backtrack and find the series of edits
which which led to uh the new string but
for fuzzy matching purposes we actually
don't care about the sequence of
sequence of strings we only care about
the difference so we only care about the
number at the very end
so what I've described to you is still
uh is still the the algorithm that's
implemented in fuzzy wuzzy or what is
what is now the fuzz or the repo
formerly known as fuzzy wuzzy uh and
it's it's the gold standard for fuzzy
matching in Python it's got It's got
almost nine nine K stars and it does
this by Computing Levin Stone distances
so uh for for work uh we we wrote um I
wrote a package called called Hot Fuzz a
very very interestingly named uh very
bad for SEO but but hopefully hopefully
it'll stick
um and it doesn't compute levenge time
distances
so
so what what does it do uh as you can
see it's quite scalable it can tackle
problems that Levinson can't solve and
and for example in this graph we can see
that it can tackle a one million uh kind
of record fuzzy matching if you're if
you're fuzzy matching it to a test set
of kind of 50k and and you can do this
within kind of the time it takes for you
to go go out for coffee or something
like that and you can you can do that on
it on a local machine
um
so how did we do it
to to understand how we did it we have
to have kind of a brief tour of NLP the
the kind of the The Arc of NLP uh is is
really kind of trying to uh represent uh
words as vectors so we go from kind of a
distributional way of looking at
language to a distributed way of looking
at language this means that kind of in
the classical era the the kind of the
kind of language models that we had were
interpretable uh but but also quite
quite High dimensional and sparse and
and the modern day uh that the kind of
kind of things that we're training that
they're very uninterpretable but they're
very low dimensional and dense so for
example something like word to vac might
have kind of 300 300 or something uh
kind of kind of um
uh yeah in in the in the hidden network
so so it's actually quite low
dimensional the dimensionality would be
kind of 300 or something like that
um and it's a very kind of dense dense
Vector
um in the classical era we have
algorithms like bag of words or bag of
engrams uh and then and then kind of uh
and then we had something uh like tfidf
which is still very distributional but
it has some very interesting
characteristics that we can use for
fuzzy mashing
uh
it's also it's also interesting to to
look at kind of things like word to vac
and and Transformers because they allow
kind of a semantic matching uh when
you're trying to fuzzy match
so I'll try to describe briefly how uh
how kind of our our library works the
it's it's got two steps one is you
create a vector space model
and then you have some kind of method to
compare these vectors
um so so what does that look like so
that could look like something like this
the method to create the vector space
model could be we break up the the
string into engrams and then we run
tfidf on it to create a vector space
model and then we need to find some kind
of method to compare these vectors that
we get at the end so the the most common
method that we use to evaluate
a kind of sequence sequence of vectors
is something like cosine similarity but
of course we iterated on this procedure
and then we went down rabbit hole and we
we found some some very interesting
things uh cosine similarity uh might
also not be the most performant some
people have developed a library that
allows for performant cosine similarity
uh that we can also think about
comparing these vectors using uh K
nearest Neighbors and in the end what we
actually ended up using was approximate
nearest neighbors so we'll get on to
that in a bit
uh so I've already described what
engrams are you can you can Define how
you want to break up your string so you
can kind of have a kind of kind of a two
gram or three gram or kind of kind of
whatever you want uh tfidf uh I'm sure
you were all kind of are aware of this
but it has some very interesting
properties when you combine it with
engrams so when you break up strings
into engrams uh the the IDF component of
TI 5df weights those engrams so that the
most uh novel engrams are represented
when you're trying to try to fuzzy match
uh so it's a very interesting kind of
side effect of tfidf
so so the second part is the the method
to compare vectors so so we we spoke
about cosine similarity
um
so the sequences are viewed as vectors
in in a product space and the cosine
similarities is the angle between them
uh so we can use the cosine similarity
from circuit learn but we found that
that was too slow uh some some people
from IGN the bank uh created a library
called sparse.top n which is written in
scythen and it and it achieves increased
speed and reduced memory consumption
because it doesn't keep the cosine
similarities for every single match it
only keeps it for kind of the top n uh
so you can reduce memory consumption by
a lot and and kind of size and help
speed it up
the
so the the other one was trying to
trying to go the k n route and K N as
implemented in psychic learn uh actually
makes things a a lot slower and
increases the the kind of the the the
the the space the space complexity but
we found that approximate nearest
neighbors was was the key in solving
this issue
so
so the the kind of so the way that our
library works is we kind of break it up
into engrams we run tfidf on it and we
use approximate numerous neighbors to do
the fuzzy matching and we found that
that's the most scalable solution that
we can have on a local machine
and kind of the the idea is to scale
this out so we can scale it out either
through the use of distributed CPU
Computing something like spark or we can
scale it out with GPU Computing like
like Rapids uh and it's kind of very
very interesting how we do uh the first
one so for example when you're trying to
fit an approximately nearest neighbors
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to build up an index and then you
you query on the index so the building
of the index can't be broadcasted to to
kind of individual workers you have to
do that in a centralized way but then
once you've done that you can actually
break up what you're trying to match the
original data set to different workers
and you can actually achieve
um achieve quite strong gains even more
than the kind of graph that I outlined
earlier so uh you know this this is very
very early days but I'm going to be uh
posting a lot about this uh this method
uh kind of kind of uh kind of both on
get and kind of on LinkedIn so
definitely if you're if you're
interested please please follow along
um I was wondering on if you have any
any kind of questions uh about the
methodology or anything else
uh yeah yeah thank you for listening
um yeah
yes so what we need to do is we need to
to break down the words into a vector
space model and the way we do that is we
use the engrams to break down a word
into engrams and then run TF IDF on the
engrams
of each of the sentences or kind of
whatever string it is you're trying to
fuzzy manage
embedding space
yes
no no
absolutely the the the that's definitely
a kind of a possibility but when you do
that the the the kind of the the
embedding space is no longer sparse so
the kind of approximate nearest neighbor
solution that we're using is very
optimized for the the sparse embeddings
um but uh that there's no reason why we
couldn't and in some cases if you want
to match kind of kind of multilingual
strings or or anything like that uh yeah
we can use all the kinds of embeddings
that we can we can do now
just on that stream I I mean kind of
related to his question is um because I
think he was alluding to perhaps using
Transformer like yes
but I guess there's a trade-off to have
if it's not involved computes yes
compared to doing a very cheap TF IDF
embedding which I guess is a lot cheaper
exactly exactly
absolutely tfrdf uh it is very cheap
compute so you can actually run it on on
just a local machine if you want and
quite easily scale it out as well
um yeah yeah sorry um it's possible that
I missed something
um when you explain the tfidf engram
sort of embedded yeah
um so it's so we can do it uh multiple
ways so so um we can actually uh you you
break up the words and then do engrams
within a word or we can actually cross
word boundaries
uh and and it's that there's a lot of
there's an art to fuzzy matching so so
I've just described the kind of the the
basic uh approach to it but but for
example that there's a lot of
pre-processing cleaning uh the data and
and these kind of things for example if
they've got punctuation errors when you
break it up into n grams kind of kind of
these kind of issues will happen so so
it's very much an art uh and and if you
for example have
um say for example you're you're trying
to fuzzy match a company's data set and
you've got 10 10 versions of the same
company uh how do you how do you find an
efficient way to to link all of those
together and to batch correct uh it it
is not and actually people have people
have actually uh created some
interesting methods uh there's a kind of
a single linkage uh kind of approach
that that someone wrote in in string
grouper uh there's a lot of interesting
kind of aspects to the more softer side
of fuzzy matching
um and and that's not what the library
is trying to explore but it's it's
something that I'm interested in because
it's it's a lot of what I do so I'll
definitely be kind of posting about
about those things uh in the future yeah
right
well no this is interesting
um I mean the Levin Stone distance can
be used to evaluate anything that you do
so even for example if you've got a very
large data set and then and then you've
done the fuzzy matching and then you've
got the best match next to it you can
use levenshine to just just double check
that you're doing the right thing uh the
the question about if the strings are
too short would the breaking up into
engrams and tfidf would that cause a
decrease in the quality of the fuzzy
match right that's the question so so
actually that's an interesting question
because we need we need a data set to
evaluate the fuzzy matching you need a
supervised data set uh the the largest
one that I found uh was the one
um actually the the larger there are
larger ones that we use at work but we I
can't really openly talk about them but
but there's one of um IMDb movies
matched to another source of movie names
and the the other source also has the
IMDb ID so so that that kind of is the
data set with a million records that we
can we can actually get get metrics out
a kind of accuracy precision recall how
good these these models do
um
that that's actually an interesting
question so so it's all about trying to
find a date set with with labels that we
can actually check what's happening to
the to the fuzzy matching and I think
that that's kind of one of the software
sides of fuzzy imagine as well
yes
um
it's it's still the ongoing
um I I find the uh
I mean I I mean I I don't see any kind
of decrease in quality
um uh if if anything it's kind of a a
better way to kind of kind of sense
check what you're doing and then you can
do a Leverage channel or whatever on top
yes Jay
um you mean the exercise you mean the
size of engram or you mean the
the oh the vocabulary size
well the for this one it's a million
records so uh
but but the the vocabulary size would be
the number of engrams right so yeah this
is the thing
um no I I actually um could you
elaborate what what do you think would
go wrong or what what do you think is
happening
it's a very interesting question
um yeah I think I think I need to
investigate that that particular thing
yeah no that's interesting
because
right
yeah
um
the the the kind of the the main issue
with the the top end is it it causes a
lot of uh errors when you want to try to
install it just uh kind of kind of
conflicts with numpy uh so
um a lot of people who've tried doing TF
IDF uh just try to avoid it even when
they try to scale out using spark
um but but it's an interesting kind of
point that the the only keeping the top
top end matches would actually eliminate
that problem
uh yes yeah yeah I think so
the k n
um I I wouldn't recommend doing it on
any
oh yeah the nnn grams so so this is I
think also another um point about the
kind of the softer side of fuzzy
matching
um you can specify uh multiple uh kind
of engrams so you can have like two and
three or kind of kind of all the way
from one to four uh and then you can
find a data set like like this the the
movies data set and then see kind of
what what works better on on that
particular data set but but each data
set is very different so we'll match on
people's names uh companies names
and and each data set uh requires a
whole new kind of pre-processing and
trying to try to think about a solution
to that
yes
yes
right
that's interesting
um and you don't need to rerun the the
that you can kind of save that and that
that's kind of removed from your data
right no that's interesting
yeah
interesting thank you
yes
um
yeah I just wanted to know how sensitive
it is to the length of the different
sequences right because in embeddings
usually I guess that that is taken care
of right by making everything say of of
Dimension 300 or 500 or whatever but but
in this case it seems like
even if even if one of the strongs is
like the substring of something else
much longer than you might think it was
yeah it's far but yeah I I I would say
it's it's quite sensitive so if you if
the two data sets are very different so
for example if you're trying to match uh
if one data set is composed mostly of
substrings of another data set uh I've
run into a lot of issues and then you
want to try to kind of do some
engineering feature engineering on the
on the side
um yeah there are issues in that regard
yep
doesn't work I was just checking out the
GitHub I can see if the code is in
published so it's it's not published um
yeah I I still haven't I still haven't
finished
um uh in the next few days so yeah it's
been a busy few days
rapid fuzz
rapid fires so rapid fuzz is a C plus
plus levenshine kind of thing but but
these kind of methods blow blow those
out of the water
um just completely it's it's on a
different scale
I just wanted to ask um obviously
of course it's based on I think
primarily based on tfida yes
the data sets that you're trying to
match are quite large you know that
Corpus is large right right
clearly your vocabulary side will be
very large yes
it's very sparse that's very smart yeah
it's a problem for you mean the the this
computer
right
yeah
um
yeah
this is the thing so
so I I think I need to run kind of kind
of rigorous tests on it find very large
data sets that I can kind of put out
there and and try to run uh run these to
completion both on the local machine and
and trying to use something like spark
and also kind of trying to use the the
Rapids kind of uh GPU kind of uh yeah so
it's it's definitely I know yeah it's
definitely going to work left to do
but yes
yes you mentioned um having to build an
index yes so did you come across the
situation where you needed to rebuild
that index how often was it was it uh
did you have any issues with that
process of rebuilding indexes the the so
in an approximate nurse neighbors I
didn't really describe approximate
nearest neighbors it's a very kind of
complex topic uh to get into but but um
the building of the index is actually
um uh kind of a much faster than the
querying side of it so so even if you
have the million records you can build
um an index on that uh and and then a
query on on and then kind of uh divide
that the 50 000 and then query
separately because querying takes a a
lot longer
um but you mean
um you mean for data that's constantly
evolving how often I need to re recreate
that index
um actually we we haven't really run
across that because the the workflows so
fast it'll finish a run would finish in
kind of an hour or something so it's
never got to the stage where it's uh
where that's an issue but that's an
interesting question I yeah I need to
kind of look into that
any any other questions or or cool cool
[Applause]